i've heard countless people say that
learning your first language is quite
different than learning a second or
third and that you can never really
learn a second language just as well
as your mother tongue that if you don't
learn a language while young
you'll never sound like a native speaker
but is that really true
hi my name is luca from lucanopano.com
and today i'm going to discuss
whether or not children really are
better language learners than adults
so when you look at the research the
overwhelming evidence
seems to point to the fact that children
are fantastically
effective language learners and that
adults are
in fact fantastically poor ones
so much so in fact that a lot of
language learning apps
use learn like a kid as a tagline to
suggest that if you use their product
you'll learn the language at a much
deeper and intuitive level
than you would otherwise you hear it
said that children
are just incredible learners they absorb
everything they learn so fast we hear
this so often that it's easy to take for
granted especially in the domain of
language learning
children are obviously fantastically
skilled language learners who can master
a language in a fraction of the time an
adult could
but the truth is that things are more
complicated than that
recently i stumbled upon a very
interesting article discussing results
of a study led by
mit scientists the study found that and
i quote
if you start learning a language before
the age of 18
you have a much better likelihood of
obtaining a native life mastery of the
language scrammer
than if you start later this is a much
older age than it's been generally
assumed and is really interesting
for reasons i'll get into a bit later
this data
also has given us a really amazing
insight into language learning in
general and shows that adults of any age
can obtain incredible mastery nearly as
quickly
as children i'm happy to say that these
findings are
in line with my own personal experience
as a long-time
language learner in fact thanks to the
very first video i made on youtube 12
years ago
i've come into contact with dozens of
incredible
language learners who have acquired
native like skills across a wide range
of languages
in some cases these people have attained
mastery
in one or two languages well beyond the
age
of 20. so what did the study at
mit find that contradicts the widespread
belief that if you don't learn a
language
before you hit puberty you're doomed to
speak like tarzan
here's my take on it for the sake of
simplicity and brevity let me break it
down
into three main areas one limiting
beliefs two
psychological obstacles and three life
circumstances
okay let's talk about limiting beliefs i
know it sounds ridiculous
but theoretically while school is
designed or at least
intended to be the place where we learn
stuff
sometimes it is the place where we
actually unlearn
things we used to do quite well and
spontaneously and that's surely the case
of language learning before you enter
school
there are no oral tests no grades and no
judgement
bestowed upon you for using the wrong
verb or preposition
in your mother tongue you acquire
language within a positive
emotional environment that does not
judge
your ability but rather fosters
communication
when adults learn a foreign language
their learning approach has changed
drastically
it has been molded to fit the learning
style that
is enforced in schools and at university
think about it for a second
how many times have you avoided speaking
a language fearing of being judged
or felt ashamed when someone pointed out
a mistake you made
how many times have you avoided
interacting in a foreign language
because
you were afraid to mess up or told
yourself that the time for speaking will
come someday
but not today as an adult language
learner all of those doubts and limiting
beliefs
only slow you down as a child learning
to speak your mother tongue
you did not have any of that you just
use the language to cooperate
play and communicate fortunately
for adult language learners all hope is
not lost
you can still learn to play and
communicate through your target language
just as kids do in fact through trial
and error
and experience adults who have
experience with language learning
become proficient proactive and at times
fearless learners who use their target
language in all possible situations and
environments
let's talk about psychological obstacles
beyond the presence or
absence of limiting beliefs there are
also significant differences
in the way that children and adults
learn and how well those learning
methods cooperate with the way the brain
naturally learns
and absorbs new information let me give
an example we're all familiar with
vocab lists if you've ever been to
language class before you've experienced
what it's like to be giving a list of
foreign language words to memorize
maybe you decided to learn these words
by repeating them out loud to yourself
over and over and over again or maybe
you were told to write down the word and
its translation several times
until you had probably memorized it
whichever way you used
in that moment you are practicing what
is called rote memorization
which is probably the memorization
technique most often promoted in school
what most people don't know is that
rogue memorization
is a very brain unfriendly way of
learning anything
studies have shown that even if you
spend hours trying to cram information
into your head through memorization
it will not stick in your head at least
not for very long
now think about how small children learn
language have you ever seen a baby
holding a vocab list
i don't think so children learn language
in the most
natural way possible through context
they see
and hear a word being used over and over
in specific situations
and then they just naturally connect the
word to its appropriate meaning and
here's the thing
kids are not perfect at this children
make mistakes with language all the time
but if they make a mistake and use the
word wrong they don't stop and cry about
it
they just adjust their understanding of
the language and keep on experimenting
this is what you as an adult need to
re-learn
you don't need to forget everything you
know but rather you need to remember
what it's like to draw connections
between concepts
in a natural way through gradual
continuous
exposure and last but not least let's
talk about life circumstances
one more place where children have a
natural advantage over adults
is their life circumstances children
lead vastly different lives than adults
do children particularly those
not yet in school have few
responsibilities and thus are free to
spend the vast majority of time playing
experimenting and simply absorbing as
much information they can
about the world around them in terms of
language they don't even have a choice
they have to learn the language they're
exposed to by their parents and
family members because it's the only way
they can survive communicate
and have their needs met adults on the
other hand
have what children do not
responsibilities
and choice we as adults have dozens
and dozens and dozens of things we have
to attend to
each day our jobs our families our
health
and much much more we don't have all of
our needs met
almost automatically as children do we
have to fend for ourselves
and in most cases that means spending a
lot of our time doing things
just to keep our lives in order with
much of our time dedicated to our
responsibilities there is
embarrassingly little time left for
non-essential things like
language learning and that's normal even
if you consider language learning
a priority the other issue that
separates adults and children
is choice as an adult you most likely do
not have an urgent
life or death need to learn your target
language you already have a language you
can use to live your life
just fine so learning a new one
is not essential and that goes even for
people who live abroad
in countries where their target language
is spoken we all know stories of expats
who only ever learn a few phrases in the
target language
even if they've lived abroad for decades
put simply
adults have the choice to learn only as
much
language as they want or need while a
child
in most cases does not so children
are naturally compelled to learn more
effectively
and one last benefit the children have
over adults
is time have you ever seen official
estimates of
how many hours of learning it takes to
learn a language to fluency
for example it is said by some
institutions that it takes about 500
hours of active learning for an english
speaker to become fluent
in say spanish and about 2
200 hours for the same english speaker
to learn
japanese to fluency that may seem like
an awful amount of time for you and me
who probably don't have more than an
hour per day to dedicate to language
learning
so let's do the math imagine that you
want to learn spanish you invest
1 hour a day 500 hours 1 hour a day
500 days japanese 2 hundred hours one
hour a day
two thousand and two hundred days that
is six
years to reach fluency that's a long
long time
especially for learning a language like
japanese do you know many adults who
have the discipline to stick to
something for
one hour a day for six years especially
if they have
a choice not to now let's take a look at
the situation for the average child
when a child is learning their mother
tongue they're immersed in it
practically
every moment of their waking lives on
average children sleep around
8-10 hours every day meaning they get to
spend 16 hours totally immersed in their
language
let's say this immersion begins the
moment they're born and continues
all the way until they turn 18. 16 hours
per day
times 365 days per year times 18 years
that makes a staggering 100 000 hours of
total language immersion
by the time you reach adulthood that
number of immersion hours is absolutely
enormous when compared to the number of
hours that are necessary to actually
reach fluency in a language as i
described earlier
children spend so much time with their
native language that they can reach
fluency in a small fraction of the time
that adults need
now the one million dollar question is
can an adult learn like a child okay
so we've covered all of the factors that
give children a huge advantage over
adults
when it comes to language learning
knowing all this is it possible to
imagine a scenario where
an adult learns a language like a child
does
i think so allow me to illustrate with a
brief story
a short time ago i was in krakow poland
working on a video for the famed easy
polish channel
on youtube specifically i worked with
yustina
and patrizia two girls who comprised the
easy polish team
well together we spent the whole day
working and filming
though we did have the occasional moment
to eat meals and relax
the whole time we spoke nothing but
polish with one another we discussed our
lives
work and a wide variety of other topics
as i practiced my polish i observed how
eustina and patrizia interacted
and used their language with one another
and how they did the same
with me from seeing these interactions i
learned
a great deal of new things about the
polish language and how it's used
eustine and patricia were also kind
enough to correct my polish when
necessary and all in all this was an
amazing
linguistic experience for that entire
day i was completely
immersed in the polish language and
culture i used it with people
heard it spoken around me and saw how
people used it
with one another and this in a nutshell
is the kind of experience children get
to live not just for one day
but for nearly every day of their lives
if an adult could live an experience
like the one i had in krakow
but do it continuously for years on end
all while maintaining an open mind
then i'm pretty sure they could reach a
native like level
eventually i truly believe that you can
acquire native life skills in any
language
at any age the older you start the more
challenging this becomes
however if you're determined the
challenge will never
become too great science supports this
while it was once thought that after the
age of 10
it's impossible to learn a language to
native like fluency studies have
actually shown that native like fluency
can be achieved even much later
after the age of 20. this is what i've
discovered in my own life
there are many adults who have reached
fluency in languages that they started
learning
long after childhood the important thing
is that these people made
conscious choices to overcome the
internal and external limitations
that adult learning so often saddles us
with
the truth is human beings best acquire
language
simply through a positive environment no
matter their age
if you can develop a solid grasp of a
language you can use this to your
advantage to greatly accelerate your
learning
especially if you move to a foreign
country and create an environment that
mimics
many of the advantageous conditions that
child learners
often find themselves in so no matter
how old you are
by the time you're watching this video
no matter what your language experiences
you can learn any language if you want
to your mind is a powerful tool
and you're infinitely capable of using
it to learn foreign languages
and change your life just as i have now
what about you
have you reached a high level in a
second language after the age of say
18 if you have then leave a comment
below
sharing your story i can't wait to read
all about it
and as always thanks for watching
[Music]
you